I wake up every mood nespresso TV go you
give this great example of how you were
on the treadmill next to Tyler Perry and
you were bold you kind of talked him up
you ended up selling him a help selling
his house but you approached him and you
said are you ready to sell one of your
houses you already knew that he owned
two houses you knew where they were you
know so isn't that also a big part of
this you have to really do the hard work
yeah and and really preparing yourself
to be lucky putting yourself in
situations where where you can get lucky
where it's not so much luck its
preparation I tell a story about how I'm
staying inside a line in starbucks and
I'm not at that starbucks because I like
coffee i'm at that starbucks because
that's where all the wealthy people and
all the celebrities in beverly hills go
every morning I meet a guy in line in
front of me I end up showing them a
house later that afternoon and he buys a
12 million dollar house some people
would say that's luck for me it's all
about being in the right place and there
was a reason why I'm there because I'm
an expert in my community and I put
myself in that situation oh wait its
prey so give me go
you